[Applause]
summers
much love on Valentine's Day Valentine's
Day and I tell you if you're a guy who
took your date to a free TV taping good
luck getting laid tonight okay but yeah
and also you have a three-day weekend
right Presidents Day Presidents Day
we've come a long way from George
Washington Appetit
why she didn't said I cannot lie I
chopped down the cherry tree Trump would
say I never met that tree
and my chopping is perfect perfect a lot
of people are saying it but guess
welcome to post democracy America where
we asked the question what if Scarface
was white well that's what happened you
know the Republican Senate has decided
it Trump is Emperor and they said if
Trump is making us money he can
basically do whatever he wants the same
way Disney was all those years with
Harvey Weinstein fans and Friends of mr.
Weinstein good to know
who always boo first it's safe
wait Weinstein's an [ __ ] I like that
well the latest in the last gasp of a
nation of dying laws was this week when
Roger stone you remember Roger stone guy
who looks like the doorman at an orgy he
is like he's Trump's original political
advisors you know that they go way back
he is known Roger over three wives and
Roger you know was the conduit between
Russia and WikiLeaks and he was
convicted of seven felonies in a fair
court done by pros and he was going to
get seven to nine in prison and then
Trump tweet unfair and of course the
Justice Department led by Bill Maher
intervenes and then Trump and Barr play
their ventriloquist game where the dummy
pretends he's mad Barr was like I'm
drawing a line in the swamp
[Applause]
Donald Trump's tweeting is making it
impossible for me to do my job yes cuz
you're supposed to be a cop but he's a
crook
Trump's the guy who asked you to bury a
dead body with him and then puts it on
YouTube so admit then this is great
Trump anon Geraldo's podcast Geraldo has
a paella and you know the entire podcast
was you know Trevor Aldo picking trumps
brain
[Music]
you thought Al Capone's vault was in so
you know that Trump on the podcast
admits it that he did in fact order Rudy
to go to Ukraine and dig up dirt on the
Biden's which was the opposite of what
he claimed in his impeachment trial
which was a whole week ago but hey you
know what we had the New Hampshire
primary on Tuesday so I guess we're
still pretending that we're having an
election and then it's gonna matter and
then he stuck ok but yeah Bernie Sanders
won Iowa and New Hampshire he's
he's also leading in the national polls
which means we have a new frontrunner
Michael Bloomberg well Bloomberg must be
the front-runner because liberals are
calling him a racist keep booing that's
how you lost the last election but now
Bloomberg does have them some blind
spots I'm not gonna lie about that he
took it on pot either well hey I will
happily vote for him if he is the
winning bidder Trump loves to mock
Bloomberg for being short but you know
what he's not short on cash he has got
ads everywhere have you seen this
they're on Facebook they're on YouTube
they're on television I saw one on
pornhub the title was rich daddy pays
for it but the good news is the field is
finally winnowing with the Democrats a
lot of them are getting out yet Michael
Bennett is out
Michael Bennett's that guy at the party
who makes sure he says good buddy and
you're like I didn't know you were here
I thought mayor Pete got the short
shrift he won I think Iowa that he's has
the most delegates and rush limbaugh
said today that the mayor Pete that's
not gonna happen because he's gay and
how's it gonna look ruch said a gay guy
kissing his husband on stage next to
mister man he said that mister man
Donald from AIDS got a point I tell you
when I see a guy wearing two pounds of
bronzer
[Laughter]
is platinum blonde comb-over teased to
perfection the first thing I think is
what a man
you